[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a very interesting time now and boy
you don't know what's gonna happen I
know that I'm proud of it I know that
we've done everything we can I really
don't know how people are gonna react to
this thing this could be anything from a
flop to a moderate single or something
that is beyond what people's
expectations are you never know you
never know good luck keeping on we were
in our own slipstream of feeling like we
were doing something a little bit
special and different but the full
circle of seeing that audiences were
reacting to it the way we had hoped they
would was powerful I had two dreams when
we started this little over 10 years ago
Morrill studio one was that I meant
working the other one was that we could
build something that was as expansive
and as experiential as what people who
read comics over the years could get I
had a lot of faith and Kevin Flagg using
people of Marvel you want to give him
everything you got cuz they're gonna
give everything that guy
this was a whole new journey by the
first Avengers but I thought oh well I
think we're on to something here
just seeing the characters together
there's something viscerally awesome
about it I think that's why the minute
Sam Jackson showed up at the end of Iron
Man 1 whether people had very common or
not
what does that mean why is he here and
then Tony Stark appearing at the end of
the Incredible Hulk I tell you we were
putting a team together who's we
though it seemed like just the tiniest
of things compared to where we are now
but those were the Foundation's that led
us here the cutting edge concept behind
the Marvel Universe is this massive
organism of shifting parts and new ideas
how do we do this as a team Seraphin is
responsible for all of these amazing
actors and actions that we brought into
this I think after the first Avengers
people realized that this was not just
an ordinary comic-book movie that there
was really a lot of thought and a lot of
care and a lot of passion that's going
into each and every one of these films
and there's also some joy I think when
the actors are having fun and creating
these characters that audiences feel bad
it's fulfilling that the characters have
just spoken to so many people all over
the world guru I love the fact that
we've been given the opportunity to do
something different put our set of ideas
forward and attack your character again
and hopefully advance on that and bring
something unique to it each time it's
wonderful to be able to play this iconic
character that means so much to people
and I really have to think the
audience's for that because they
embraced my portrayal of her from the
beginning final fitting what do you
think questions comments concerns and
allowed me to walk in Natasha's shoes
and kick ass in them too
I can tell you that each and every one
of us is so grateful our lives are
monumentally changed by our involvement
in this world to have taken such an
instrumental role in what Marvel has
done in the past ten years it's just so
incredibly meaningful to us this is a
cool experiment to be a partner it's
epic and classical these characters are
mythological characters in a lot of ways
I love all of you and I look forward to
seeing many of you as we trudge this
road of happy destiny it's nice to look
at how the legacy is living on in these
other movies and other filmmakers I
don't think this has ever happened
before in cinematic history of all these
different franchises colliding and all
these storylines they've started such a
long time ago have all woven together
you guys as the film's have progressed
with civil war and now infinity war
we're just gonna continue to surprise
people
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more
the entire time I knew him he only ever
had one goal
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
danos
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan tears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
Wow
the end is near
une undone
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as all things should be
I hope that remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange oh
you're using your made-up names then I
am spider-man
[Music]